French firefighters have gone on strike
in the city of Lyon demanding better pay
and conditions
firefighters blocked streets in the city
as they marched with torches and banners
the walkout comes just ahead of the
world-famous festival of lights which
attracts thousands of visitors to the
city from around the world France has
also been gripped by demonstrations
against fuel tax increases which has it
been led by people wearing bright yellow
vests president Milan reacted to the
mass discontent
his reforms have caused the movement
this movement has generated significant
protest and also unacceptable violence
in france's mainland and in its overseas
territories what was said during the
presidential campaign has to stand
regardless of whether you backed me in
the election we can't on a Monday be in
favor of the environment then on Tuesday
be against fuel price increases we can't
decide some years ago to have a tax
increase
only now to denounce it several hundred
thousand people have now taken part in
what has become weekly demonstrations
protesters told us that they will not
stop until macron reverses his policy
the French people are not asking for too
much we are demanding employment and an
end to these excessive fuel taxes there
are some people who are angry in a
resorting to violence because they're
against everybody but the government
really has to do more to address
people's legitimate concerns many people
made a mistake in voting for this
government
so now young people are angry I was hit
in the face by grenade from the riot
police there was an explosion close by
this won't change anything what we want
is to raise the minimum wage and cut
fuel crisis the environment is not a
priority for French people at the moment
we'll keep protesting and this won't
stop us despite the victims it has
shamed that it cost such violence
you